.
- Bonjour, merci.
- Monsieur Singh, deuxième
campagne électorale à la tête
du NPD. Cette fois-ci,
avec deux fois plus d'argent,
de moyens financiers qu'en 2019.
Un seul siège de plus.
Ça fait cher du siège.
JAGMEET SINGH
- Ha! ha! ha! Mais on est
tellement fiers de la campagne
qu'on a faite parce qu'on a eu
la chance de partager notre
message. On a eu la chance
de partager les défis des gens,
de parler et de souligner
comment on veut améliorer
la vie des gens.
- Mais ça ne marche pas, ça.
Les gens... vous n'avez pas
de sièges de plus.
- Je pense que ce qu'on a fait,
on a vraiment augmenté notre
fondation. On a augmenté l'appui
à travers le pays. On a augmenté
le nombre de gens qui ont voté
pour nous. On est le seul parti
d'opposition qui a gagné plus
de sièges. Donc, c'était une
élection un peu bizarre, mais
malgré tout ça, on a vraiment
réussi à convaincre les gens
qu'on est une option. Mais oui,
ça reste... le travail continue,
et on doit continuer le travail,
particulièrement au Québec.
- Comment vous faites pour
convaincre les gens? Comment
vous faites pour traduire cet
appui-là en sièges, en députés?
Parce que ça, ça ne fonctionne
pas pour l'instant.
- Et c'est la grande question.
On va faire une analyse.
On en a embauché quelques-uns
pour le faire, pour identifier
stratégiquement qu'est-ce qu'on
doit faire. On s'est rapprochés,
on était plus proches pour
gagner plus de sièges, mais il
y a quelque chose qui manque et
on va faire une analyse. Parce
que je crois profondément que
les gens vont être mieux servis
avec un député néo-démocrate.
- Vous avez... la campagne a
beaucoup tourné autour de vous.
Ça a été une campagne centrée
autour du chef. Est-ce que
c'était une erreur?
- Non, je pense que c'est
important pour les gens.
Les gens connaissent les chefs
de parti. Et j'ai un bon appui
dans les gens, donc ça, c'est
quelque chose qui est une force,
c'est important. Mais on va
aussi analyser comment on peut,
ou évaluer comment on peut
améliorer notre travail sur
le terrain. Et comme j'ai dit,
pour moi, je veux gagner
à travers le pays, ça veut dire
au Québec aussi. Et il y a
du travail qu'il reste,
du travail qu'on doit faire.
- Le gouvernement évalue
présentement les programmes
d'aide qui ont été instaurés
pendant la pandémie. On doit
déterminer s'ils seront
prolongés. Vous avez déjà
indiqué cette semaine que vous
vouliez voir une prolongation
de certains programmes d'aide,
pour les gens, pour les petites
entreprises, entre autres.
Combien de temps ça doit durer,
d'après vous?
- Je pense qu'un chiffre,
une façon d'évaluer comment,
où on doit arrêter, c'est que
premièrement, on doit faire face
à la pandémie. Et maintenant,
on est dans une quatrième vague
de cette pandémie. Donc, ça peut
nous donner une façon d'évaluer
quand on doit arrêter.
Au moins, on doit être sûr
qu'on a vraiment combattu
cette pandémie.
- Mais là, on est pas dans
la même dynamique. Les commerces
sont ouverts. Il y a des gens
qui vont manger au restaurant.
On n'est pas comme en début
de pandémie où tout était
complètement fermé. Là, il y a
une activité économique. Il y a
des gens qui disent : "C'est
programmes d'aide là, ils nous
empêchent d'aller chercher
la main-d'oeuvre dont on a
besoin." On arrête où?
- J'ai dit qu'en ce moment,
en Alberta et en Saskatchewan,
on a la pire situation. C'est
maintenant, en ce moment, pire
que jamais dans tous les 18 mois
de cette pandémie. Donc, ça
montre comment on est vraiment
au milieu de cette pandémie.
Deuxièmement, quand on parle
de l'aide pour les petites
entreprises, on est vraiment
spécifique. Cette aide doit
être... on doit la livrer
pour les petites entreprises.
Parce que les grands magasins,
les grandes entreprises
étaient toujours dans une bonne
position. Mais c'était
les petites entreprises
dans nos communautés locales
où on a vu les grands impacts
de cette pandémie.
On doit les continuer.
- Donc, il n'y a pas de moments
où vous vous dites : "Encore
pour un autre trois mois,
ou six mois, ou neuf mois"?
Il n'y a pas de date
de péremption pour vous?
- Pas en ce moment parce qu'avec
la réalité sur le terrain, le
fait qu'en Alberta en ce moment,
en Saskatchewan en ce moment,
c'est vraiment la pire situation
avec une crise dans les
hôpitaux, avec une crise avec
les gens qui tombent malades,
donc en ce moment, c'est bien
évident qu'on est dans une
quatrième vague qui frappe fort.
- Vous avez dit déjà que vous
étiez prêt à collaborer avec
le gouvernement. On vous perçoit
comme l'allié naturel des
libéraux. Elle est où, la ligne
où vous décidez que vous
n'appuyez pas le gouvernement?
- On est prêt à voter contre le
gouvernement. N'importe quand.
On est prêt à faire ça. Mais
la différence entre moi et les
autres partis d'opposition, mon
but, ce n'est pas de chercher un
moment pour voter non. Mon but,
c'est de trouver des façons
de faire fonctionner
ce gouvernement pour les gens.
Donc, je n'ai pas une ligne
rouge ou une ligne orange, j'ai
des valeurs. Et les valeurs sont
comment on peut aider les gens,
comment on peut investir dans
nos soins de santé. Il y a
des mesures immédiates qu'on
veut voir. Un programme de
congés de maladie payés, c'est
quelque chose qu'on a demandé.
On veut voir qu'ils arrêtent
tout de suite de continuer
les poursuites contre les
enfants autochtones. Quelque
chose que la cour de justice
a dit que vous devez arrêter,
et maintenant, on dit clairement
qu'ils doivent prendre
l'engagement d'arrêter. Donc, il
y a plusieurs mesures comme ça.
- La ligne de cassure pour vous,
elle est où?
- C'est vraiment si ça aide les
gens ou non. Donc, on est prêt
à voter non, on est prêt à voter
contre le gouvernement,
mais ce n'est pas mon but.
- Mais pas maintenant. Vous
n'êtes pas prêt à repartir
en élection demain matin?
- On pourrait le faire n'importe
quand, mais pour nous, pour moi,
c'est vraiment, on est dans une
pandémie, on est dans une crise,
on doit régler cette crise.
Ça, c'est pour moi prioritaire.
- Alors, combien de temps
il va... combien de temps
ce gouvernement-là va durer
d'après vous?
- Si c'était ma décision, je dis
qu'on va continuer de faire le
travail pour tout notre mandat
parce que le gouvernement
a été choisi par les gens...
- Mais c'est un peu votre
décision. C'est votre décision
quelque part, non?
- Mais dans le passé, c'était
le gouvernement libéral
qui a décidé de déclencher
une élection.
- Donc vous, vous êtes prêt
à appuyer le gouvernement
pour la durée du mandat
si ça vous convient?
- Si ça convient aux gens,
si ça aide les gens, si ça livre
la marchandise pour les gens,
oui. Mais sinon, on est prêt
à voter contre aussi.
- Monsieur Singh, il y aura un
retour en chambre éventuellement
des parlementaires. Vous le
voyez comment, ce retour-là?
- Je pense que le système
hybride a fonctionné. Ça a donné
une opportunité pour les gens
qui ont des familles, qui ont
des défis pour aller à Ottawa de
se présenter et de participer.
Donc, je suis pour
un système hybride.
- Donc, à 50-50? À 60...
Quel genre de proportion
vous envisagez?
- On doit suivre les conseils
des experts en matière
de santé publique pour donner
une distanciation physique
entre les gens. Donc, je suis
ouvert aux discussions
qui suivent les conseils
des experts.
- Un retour avec tout le monde
en chambre, ce n'est pas ce que
vous envisagez ou ce n'est pas
ce que vous préférez, c'est ça?
- Non, en ce moment,
je pense que ce n'est pas
la bonne chose à faire.
- Jagmeet Singh, m